عرض رسومي يصور
أبو ظبي بواسطة طائرة بدون طيار ليلاً ،
تلتقط الصورة حجم الطاقة اللازمة
لتشغيل العاصمة
، الأمر الفريد هنا هو أن الإمارات العربية المتحدة
هي أول دولة عربية تولد الضوء
من
قوتها النووية في هذا المبنى ، ولدينا
أكبرها  مولد كهربائي في الشرق الأوسط ،
شارك محمد الحمادي
منذ اليوم الأول في
أخذ نموذج عمل شوهد هنا
لإطلاق العمليات التجارية
الآن نحن مرتبطون تجاريًا
بالشبكة ونحقق إيرادات
ونرسل أيضًا كهرباء آمنة نظيفة وموثوقة
للشبكة  وهذه
الأرواح كما ترون الآن
لديها أيضًا جزء من محطة الطاقة النووية
هذه ، كل ذلك تم إنشاؤه هنا في منشأة البركة
النووية
على بعد 300 كيلومتر جنوب غرب أبو
ظبي بالقرب من حدود المملكة العربية
السعودية وقطر
هذه المنشأة بها أربعة مفاعلات رقم
واحد الآن  الرقم الثاني الذي يعمل بكامل طاقته
محمل بالوقود وسيتوفر ثلاثة وأربعة
على الإنترنت
خلال السنوات القليلة المقبلة عندما يكون كل شيء
قال وفعلت البركة ستوفر حوالي
من الكهرباء في البلاد ، وستعمل أربع وحدات
من محطات الطاقة النووية على تجنب
ما يقرب من 21 مليون طن من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون
على أساس سنوي ، وهذا منظور حالي
للجمهور
الذي يبلغ حوالي 3.2 مليون سيارة من
الطريق
الذي سلكته الإمارات  قفزة كبيرة في هذا المجال
بوضع إطار السياسة في عام
2008 وإنفاق 24 مليار دولار
لتطوير القطاع
أكثر من ثلاثة آلاف عامل في
الموقع ، وستين بالمائة من مواطني الإمارات
مثل ألم النعيمي التي حصلت على شهادتها
قبل خمس سنوات
في الهندسة النووية  إنه فريد من نوعه ،
إنه جديد في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة وأردت أن أكون
جزءًا من هذا المشروع الجديد
المهم عندما ذهبت إلى الجامعة ،
لم تكن هذه الخطة موجودة ،
لذا بمجرد تخرجي ، عرضت هذه الوظيفة
علي خبرة كبيرة في جميع
جوانب البيئة.
نظرة حصرية داخل
مبنى التوربينات في المنطقة المحمية
كنت هنا في عام 2017 وكان
صامتًا لأنه لم يكن قيد التشغيل ومن
الواضح أنه تغير
و  أستطيع أن أشعر بالحرارة مع تدفق البخار
مباشرة إلى التوربينات التي ورائي
، ارتفعت درجة الحرارة إلى 47 درجة
مئوية
أو 116 درجة فهرنهايت حيث
عبرت المنشأة
عتبة العمليات التجارية ، يعتقد معظم الناس
أن الإمارات العربية المتحدة منتج
للنفط والغاز ثقيل على
الهيدروكربونات  هل يغير هذا
السرد الذي يأتي عبر الإنترنت تجاريًا ،
فأنا أتفق معك تمامًا
والنقطة الرئيسية هنا
هي أن الإمارات العربية المتحدة تعمل على
تنويع اقتصادها وتنويع مواردها
في كهربة الطاقة
سيكون أحد الركائز الأساسية
لإزالة الكربون وستكون أيضًا عاملًا
أساسيًا لـ  النمو
الاقتصادي للعالم مع تزايد الطلب على البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي ،
كذلك ستزداد الكهرباء والحاجة
إلى تلبية هذا النمو
بعدد أقل من الوقود الأحفوري
مدفوعًا بتقسيم الذرة.